okay i want to start by talking about
your moment at the acm awards
like the history making moment here
first black women to perform
at the acms i know that this is it must
have been a thrilling moment but there's
also like
like a weight to that as well isn't
there yeah yeah
it's it's crazy first of all like being
the first african-american to perform
her original country song on
the awards it was again i didn't
understand the gravity until
after the performance and it's it is
heavy
because you're celebrating but you know
again we're still in a pandemic
there's still so much inequality not
just for women of color
but white women as well and it's still
really really hard so as
amazing as that moment is and i
appreciate it and i receive it like we
still have a lot of work to do
and do you feel like that that message
is being received
loud and clear in the music industry and
country music industry
i mean i'm hoping so i'm i'm doing
everything that i can
to to fight and and
and spread love and and encourage people
to
want to be a part of this change but
only time will tell
you know we still have to look at the
country radio charts and see that
there's only one woman in the top 20
right now
i don't know why that is and so many
amazingly talented
hard-working women yeah right yeah it's
true
you know it's there's so many great
songs on there even i have a new song
that
you know i'm still struggling to get on
the charts it's it's something that
you know i don't know why it is but we
just have to continue
praying and hoping and opening our
mouths and informing people that this is
happening so that hopefully they can be
a part of this change as well
yeah now i know that the the awards were
a socially distanced affair
so it was its own thing
in terms of like doing an awards show
but did you have a chance to interact
with
um with the other artists in any way
that were there
um during radio remotes i got to see a
couple of artists like to neil towns i
saw her i saw
kelsey ballerini i saw cam we've taken
i think all of us took like five coveted
tests
before even seeing each other but we
didn't get to have that much interaction
no
it was very quiet and the only person i
really saw was keith
the actual day of the awards they very
much so kept us all separate what was it
like having keith urban
up there oh my god when we were
rehearsing
i forgot the lyrics to my own song a
couple of times that was so
i remember i was like so nervous and
then i look over at keith
who's a guitar player you know he's not
a piano player but the fact that he did
and he
looked at me and his hands were shaking
like this and i was like
what are you doing so nervous i'm the
one that's supposed to be
more nervous but it was it just shows
how human and lovely he is
it's just again it's still crazy to
think that that happened
i i it still doesn't feel like it
happened
when you're in a scenario like that like
you're going to be
working with someone who you know that
you've like looked up to for so long you
know that they're
such a big deal how do you actually get
over that
sort of nervous energy like do you try
to play it cool like hey
oh we're gonna do this together like
yeah we're good
i totally tried to keep it cool until it
was time to rehearse and i was
forgetting the lyrics to my song and
then that's when the real human eyes
the human part of me came out but you
know
they always say never meet your heroes
but i was so lucky to get to meet one of
my heroes keith who
is such a gracious human being like he's
been through so much he's so
pro-supporting women and just a kind
person and he helped with those nerves
seeing how human he is and seeing
how how kind he is
even though he's you know hello he's
married to nicole kidman
and has a massively successful career
and
he's still so kind and it goes to show
you being kind
really matters more than anything and
i'm just happy
that i got to be graced with his
presence yes graced with this
that's kind of how it is right yeah yeah
yeah that's how i felt i like i can be
knighted now
[Laughter]
how does it feel though you know on the
flip side for you knowing that even you
just knew
stepping out there doing that
performance
now you're going to be looked at like
that by people you know what i'm saying
like young girls are going to look at
you and go
that i want to be that well it's so
important to me that that i mentor
future artists because you know
in order for us to get here someone has
a mentor us and
and it means a lot and i take that job
very seriously and i
hope women that want to be musicians
black
or indigenous or latina
whatever i hope they feel that they can
come to me
and and that i'll support them because
that's what that's what they deserve and
that's
what i i want to give them those
opportunities it's so important
to mentor the future and that's what i
want and i'm planning on doing
and i try to do and there's now there's
going to be um
a whole other layer to that like there's
it's one thing to be
to have people see you from a distance
and think
i i want to be that one day now you've
got a little life
that's coming where you get to directly
be
you know i mean everything the world to
this person
yeah it's heavy too i'm not gonna lie
i'm like you know now that the award
shows have
ended and i've been able to like really
focus on this baby because i haven't
exactly gotten to do that i didn't have
a registry ready
and so you know now i've been thinking
about it and i'll be
talking to my husband like oh my god i
have this baby that we're going to have
to take care of
forever and it's just
you know it's it's crazy and i'm gonna
whip that child into shape and
i've prayed for this baby and and will
love this baby no matter
who they turn out to be who they love i
pray for a husband
and a wife whatever this baby wants i'm
praying for
their their significant other and man
it's it's crazy yeah i mean i know i
know so many parents that
are really intent on having their child
do the thing that they love and that's
i think that's lovely to build a bond to
what is it
how are you guys treated it's gonna be
music from the moment the
i mean i'm sure this music even the
babies hearing the music now yeah but
when they're out and they're actually
able to express do you want them to
do your child to follow in your
footsteps i want my child to just be
whomever this child is supposed to be
i want this child to have freedom of
choice
and and the freedom to be like
the moment this child has been conceived
it's its own person
like i like i i may be the vessel i'm
the mother
but this child is its own person and i
want to teach that child
this child to be that and i will love
this baby no matter what it wants to be
when it grows up no matter who it wants
to love
like i just want this baby to feel
supported
and to do whatever it is that they want
to do
but hard work has to be a part of it i
will teach a child to be a hard worker
okay
but i want i want them to have their own
their own
just be their own person because i'm
very much so a very independent person
and i want
i wanted to be treated like that you
know yeah
now i know that um pregnancy hits
different for everybody
and everybody has their own experience
about how they feel
what's yours been like so far you know
honestly when i first found out
that i was pregnant i was terrified
i mourned my former life to be honest
i was like you know like everything that
i was i'm not bad anymore i'm not my own
anymore
and i was also scared that the baby was
going to affect my career
which was a horrible i had a deep
program my mind to think that
as a woman i can have a family and have
a career too
so i had to do a lot of deprogramming of
my mind
to to accept this because i was just
in complete shock like it's terrifying
it was not an instagramable
moment when i found out that i was
pregnant like i looked at that
pregnancy stick and was just like
exactly like what the hell am i doing
but um yeah it's crazy yeah yeah but
it's like
it's one of the realest moments you'll
have ever experienced and even you
saying even you being able to admit you
know like
i had these reservations and i had these
fears because the thing is
there's a lot of expectation especially
on a mother not so much on a father but
especially on the mother about how
you're supposed to be
and you know that in the coming months
you're going to get a lot of people kind
of telling you the way they think it
should be
yeah and how are you going to deal with
that
i'm going to tell them to mind their own
business this is my pregnancy not there
i'm just kidding but um you know i would
take all
advice i'm you know i'm trying to be as
honest about my pregnancy as possible
and the fears that i've legitimately had
and you know everybody's different i'm
taking a very practical stance i feel
you know i'm i'm trying to be very
practical
about what my life is going to look like
that i don't know what i'm doing but i
am terrified that i'm not gonna be a
perfect mother and i just hope
i'm just gonna give myself grace to to
know that i'm not gonna be perfect
and i'm not you know reading a thousand
books on how to be a mother
i'm not you know again i don't even have
my registry started i don't have a
nursery i don't have anything
i'm over four months so
you know i'm just gonna take i'm just
gonna figure it out
yeah do you have any any uh names picked
out yet is that one of the things where
you're like i don't want to tell
family whatever like what our name
choices are going to be because they
always have an opinion
oh yeah i already have my name my mom
wanted part of her name to be in this
i'm like mom
you can't you can't have the child's
name but you can't
i do have a name picked out right away
like i know what i'm having
this baby is set ready to go as far as
the name and
yeah yeah did did you get inspired
uh musically i know you said like the
moment was like a shock moment
but when things sort of settled in
emotionally were you inspired musically
by
what's going on with you right now i
think absolutely i was your life
instantly changes like you instantly
are a different person the moment you
find out
and
yeah my i was inspired because
i want to inspire change so that my
child doesn't have to go through
the hardships that i did or that all of
us have
you know i want more equality i want
this baby to have the exact same
opportunities
as everybody else and it has inspired it
was
inspired a lot of this ep and my song
bridges and
even watching the protests and seeing
all that was happening in downtown l.a a
lot of all of it's inspired
my writing